Hi, maybe this is called an explosive
because it still leaves
cassava sap in a brownish color. This is
an icon for Bantul, also in Yogyakarta
[Music]
in the
center. My name is Yasir very smart.
one
thing he founded this company and
invited people around here
to work because at that time the
people around here were still in Dutch colonial conditions, it was
difficult for
food
production. We saw production only
on a social basis, so we couldn't
get the maximum profit
[Music]
MP4 Hi,
the ingredients for milad are
tapioca flour, cassava flour, water,
we form squares for us to steam
or we steam the hardest part for
this milad, we do steaming or in
Steam, we
still use As firewood,
we steam it there, we mix it
until it's smooth
a b u just entered my press machine
on Steam again or steamed again
we leave it or we are wanted one
night
In the morning we soak it in plain water
we wash it to get rid of the
sap-like
so we dry it more or less
until 02.00 in the afternoon starting from
06.00 in the morning
it's so dry we pack it
ready to be registered
hi hi
hi hi hi hi
Hi
, Milad's taste is that it will be chewier
and more savory,
hi mei lattek edit. Served usually
with fried noodles or boiled noodles or
say mixed noodles or here, in
Magelang language, mixed with rice,
by saying the mask is put on this, there are
shrimp, chicken,
eggs or normal FB, FB
explodes, reminds me with  at home because
now I eat noodles the most, namely
in restaurants with friends or
with family
hi
hu hu